[Applaudissements]
merci ça marche
alors c'est vrai que j'ai ce set
horrible privilège de fermer la valse et
quand on m'a contacté pour participer à
ce qu'a dit que je dis mais qu'est ce
que vous voulez que je vous dise
j' ai pas inventés de vaccins j'ai pas
inventé le fil à couper le beurre j'ai
pas inventé la pilule contre la bêtise
j'aurais bien voulu parce qu'à mon avis
j'aurais fait fortune
surtout en ce moment et c'est vrai que
pour que je puisse vous faire votre ma
présentation je vais quand même prendre
le petit la petite télécommande est ce
que je peux avoir la télécommande
s'il vous plaît voilà super merci
alors c'est vrai que 18 minutes pour
changer le monde ces slogans comme avant
du mois en 18 minutes j'arrive même pas
me changer on va quand même essayer de
faire quelque chose alors changer le
monde peut être mais en tout cas je me
suis dit que j'allais vous expliquer le
parcours que j'ai réussi à accomplir
je n'ai pas envie d'être très
égocentrique donc j'ai choisi deux
anecdotes ou deux périodes clés dans ce
que j'ai accompli et tout ça j'ai voulu
le bédié dans une notion que j'ai
découverte on va dire sur le terrain et
d'un point de vue conceptuel
c'est la résilience et c'est pour ça que
j'ai intitulé cette intervention
chronique d'une résilience ordinaire et
le tout baigné dans une métaphore parce
que j'adore les métaphores et c'est ce
qui permet finalement d'illustrer de la
meilleure manière possible et vous allez
voir que finalement on peut tout
expliquer avec des métaphores et
notamment la musique qui fait partie
intégrante de ma vie la métaphore c'est
jouer contre la contre mais l'audi de la
mélodie
vous verrez à la fin pourquoi j'ai
choisi cette métaphore alors
la résilience c'est une notion que
certains d'entre vous ont dit de courir
avec boris cyrulnik est un éthologue
donc il étudie les comportements humains
et animaux et pour lui sa définition la
résidence est l'art de naviguer dans les
torrents vous verrez que il ya aussi
beaucoup d'autres métaphore qu'on peut
utiliser la résilience à la base c'est
aussi la capacité on en parle dans la
physique des matériaux
la capacité d'un matériau données de
reprendre sa forme initiale une fois
qu'il a été soumis à des stress
particulier c'est la même chose pour les
êtres humains et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que toutes les interventions qu'on
a vu jusqu'à maintenant ont un point
commun la résilience que ça soit le
sourire de reda que ça soit jafar qui a
dépassé l'obstacle premier au début de
sa vie en lui disant mais tu n'arriveras
jamais à faire ce que tu es devenu
maintenant la résilience de woods a
aussi à travers son voyage et c'est vrai
que cette notion-là accompagne et nous
accompagnent tous mémoire celle dont je
vais parler c'est pas celle de ses
grands trop main c'est simi traumatisme
que l'on peut vivre au quotidien et
notamment chez nous au maroc avec toutes
ses contradictions qu'on est obligé
d'appréhender qu'on est obligé de
comprendre et en quoi ça peut devenir
une force alors j'ai choisi également
je vais vous la laisse est long mais
c'est un extrait des vilains petits
canards de boris cyrulnik
je les ai parcouru je vous le cache pas
hier soir je me suis longtemps demandé
contre quoi un nom je pouvais se
rebeller puisque tout est parfait au
paradis jusqu'au jour où j'ai compris
qu'il se révolter contre la perfection
un ordre irréprochable provoqué en lui
un sentiment de non vie et justice
absolue en supprimant les aiguillons de
lundi nation engourdissent et son humble
les aiguillons
de l'indignation chez nous des écuyers
de l'indignation en a un paquet agra
alors je vais rabaisser le niveau
culturel
je suis désolé j'adore les voitures
alors je me suis dit la résidence la
meilleure manière aussi de d'illustrer
la résilience c'est vous savez ce que
c'est là en bas à gauche
non c'est un volant d'inertie dans une
porsche supercar est en haut vous avez
une bagnole ou c'est le système
finalement de récupération de l'inertie
issus du freinage pour faire avancer la
voiture
bah moi c'est comme ça que je vois tous
ces petits obstacles que vous avez dans
la vie de tous les jours qui vous font
freiner et qui au lieu de vous stopper
net vous permettre d'avancer alors
lorsque j'ai voulu également un peu plus
approfondir sur la notion de résilience
et l'appliquer à ma vie a finalement
pour vous faire partager voir de quelle
manière on peut avancer malgré tout
c'est tous ces petits obstacles tous ces
petites contradictions qu'on peut sentir
chez nous et qu'on peut vivre au
quotidien
eh bien je me suis dit on va trouver
d'autres je trouvais des exemples et
j'ai envie aujourd'hui je vais en
profiter pour finalement revenir sur une
injustice absolument incroyable qui est
fait à ces deux animaux qui sont d'une
résilience extraordinaire ça va vite
le cafard îles à 250 millions d'années
il a un exosquelette qui lui permet de
s'adapter à son environnement et il est
capable de résister à des radiations
alors je sais pas je connais pas le
ratio par rapport à nous mais d'une
manière incroyable et nous on le déteste
et enfin
lane un animal d'une résilience
extraordinaire mais qui est capable
d'avancer dans des chemins escarpés
d'une difficulté absolument incroyable
et nous on en fait notre injures la plus
horrible pour un maroquin celle de
traité de l'amour et ces deux espèces en
une résilience incroyable et j'ai un
point commun avec celui là c'est que je
suis têtu comme une mule plus on me dit
de pas faire quelque chose plus vu le
faire et c'est ça qui m'a accompagné
c'est ça qui m'a accompagné finalement
pendant toute ma carrière on c'est vrai
que bon j'ai fait énormément de choses
mais c'est vrai que depuis ces deux
dernières années ça s'est accéléré je
dors pas beaucoup la nuit je fais de la
radio j'ai fait de la télé
j'en parlerai bien évidemment mais je
veux dire j'en profitais pour vous
donner cette anecdote que je vous ai
promis sur ce premier point focal qui
m'a vraiment décidé à faire de la
résilience pas mon mode de vie mais en
tout cas mon moteur est pas cette
résilience qui vous bloque comme un
lièvre coincé dans les phares d'une
voiture
ok j'ai une contradiction j'ai un
problème je vais l'encaisser mais je
suis bloqué je veux pas avancer c'est
pas celle là qui m'intéressent
pour ça je vous donnais une anecdote
quand j'ai commencé ma vie
professionnelle j'ai travaillé j'avais
un bon poste et j'ai travaillé pour une
grande entreprise en tant que
prestataire pour une grande entreprise
non je vais pas dire le nom mais qui
commence par mae qui finit par comme et
à ce moment là ces gens là sont venus me
voir et m'a dit voilà on a travaillé
avec vous a été prestataires il ya un
directeur de la stratégie qui part et on
a envie de vous proposer pour ce poste
alors moi j'avais 23 ans
c'est un super salaires qui se profilait
à l'horizon
j'ai par fait de grandes études j'ai un
bac + 2 et j'avais fait du bon boulot il
avait bossé jour et nuit pour prouver à
ce client que j'étais capable
et la preuve c'est qu'on m'a appelé je
passe par les différents pôles de
direction ok c'est bon ok c'est bon ok
c'est bon et un moment on me dit ab il
ya une dernière étape
il va falloir que tu passes c'est le
directeur des cadres à haut potentiel
déjà l'appellation disait cadres à haut
potentiel c'est à dire tout le reste y a
pas de potentiel
ok mais à l'époque ça ok j'ai déjà une
manière de me dire que j'avais du
potentiel
je vais c'est ce monsieur là je commence
à lui expliquer pourquoi on avait
proposé à ce poste là qu'ils étaient
importants
c'est un poste de directeur de stratégie
j'allais sur mes 24 ans je vous le
répète encore une fois et je lui dis
mais voyez d'un point de vue stratégique
nous avons fait toutes les études
complémentaires qui nous permettrait
d'avoir une segmentation ciblées pour
les aurait donnés à venir le blabla le
game arts fnla la balle à la cité de la
wii qu'est ce que vous avez comme
diplôme
je faisais un bac + 2 il avait une
magnifique moustache bouche là mais
vraiment là la moustache de chant d'art
je vois déjà un oeil qui commence à
partir de côté on continue la discussion
me dire mais moi je connais rien
marketing monsieur c'est de la vie
combien vous demandez pour le poste et à
ce moment là je tempère par cet espace
doit faire gratiner qu'on auto
entretient chez nous en me disant que le
poste qui était avant c'était un
français que moi quand je suis au maroc
avec mon expérience j'ai demandé 75 % du
salaire que touche et l'ancien directeur
vous savez ce qui m'a répondu il m'a
répondu
enfin système des oui vous êtes
marocains et vous savez ce que je lui
dis à ce monsieur aujourd'hui vous savez
ce que je dis ah ben je dis que ça
marche plus voilà ça ça fait partie des
huit ni traumatisme qui arrivent dans la
vie mais c'est pas grave je lui dis
merci je lui dis merci tous les jours
que dieu fait parce que sans lui
j'aurais pas accompli beaucoup de choses
parce que sans lui je n'aurais pas
appris à travailler sans filet parce que
sans lui j'aurais jamais osé quoi que ce
soit c'est ce jour là où je me suis dit
jamais je ne serai plus salarié de ma
vie alors tout cela sur la notion de
résilience
c'est vrai que on l'a dit tout à l'heure
on sortait de la coop 22 et cette notion
elle est venu très souvent puisque sans
aller dans les détails cette notion de
résilience on la voit de manière
concrète
lorsque pendant la coupe 22 justement
d'un discuté longuement que des fonds
doivent être débloqués pour des nations
comme les nôtres que non qu'il émet très
peu de gaz à effet de serre
et que nos agriculteurs n'ont pas besoin
l'atténuation et de fonds pour s'adapter
et on a parlé de résilience et cette
résilience
elle est quotidienne cette résilience et
les quotidiennes dans la gestion je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure de nos
contradictions
voilà c'est vrai convient des
contradictions la dernière anecdote et
que je vais venir parce que c'est chaud
et je vous la faire partager
c'est quand vous êtes à des moments de
votre vie vous êtes sûr d'avoir fait un
travail magnifique
vous êtes sûr que vous êtes défoncer
comme il fallait
oui mais non mais j'ai vous êtes content
de ce que je fais oui va continuer non
ok vous gagnez de l'argent avec moi oui
donc on va continuer on va faire mieux
non on se dit à un moment que le rempart
de la rationalité est importante
ce rempart de la rationalité on se dit
que c'est la dernière chose à laquelle
on se rattache
quand on fait face à des situations
qu'on ne comprend pas quand la
rationalité disparaît on se dit on fait
quoi on rebondit au robot dit en avance
au lieu de rester figé dans les phares
de la bagnole comme le lièvre ou comme
le chat qu'on a vu et ça je vous le dis
pourquoi c'est chaud parce que je n'ai
encore jamais dit mais je vais le dire
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure j'ai une
chose dont je suis très fier et qui est
très fraîche
c'est cette émission de télévision qu'on
a fait l'année dernière et pourquoi j'en
suis très fier non pas d'un point de vue
seulement personnel mais c'était la
première émission dans l'histoire de la
télé marocaine quotidienne en direct et
en français dans un contexte
et surtout dans le contexte que vous
connaissez et surtout où on a libéré la
parole d'une manière absolument
incroyable on a parlé absolument de tout
et aujourd'hui on ne fait plus cette
émission et je suis comme vous
pour beaucoup de gens qui me demandent
je sais pas pourquoi
même le oui mais non on me l'a pas
donnée alors je serais revenu dix ans en
arrière j'aurais été et gris j'aurais
éclaté
j'aurais dit mais c'est pas possible non
on la chose que j'ai fait tout
simplement c'est de me dire ok avec ça
qu'est ce que je vais faire après et
c'est ce que je suis en train de faire
alors là dans quoi je baigne un peu tout
ça est la métaphore est ce qui me permet
mois d'avancé
c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de
mon adn or je sais pas comment ça se
transmet je ne sais pas comment nos
molécules hainaut particules résonne on
a eu de la musique en début de de cette
session et c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé
à résidents des dissonances harmonieuse
je vous ai pas encore dit pourquoi j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de jouer la contre
mélodies de la mélodie et je parle de
dissonances harmonieuse pourquoi
dissonances harmonieuse parce que même
dans la musique
vous avez a demandé moment donné ce
qu'on appelle des dissonances
si vous les sortez de leur contexte
c'est ce que vous allez appeler une
fausse note
si vous êtes dans un morceau de musique
entre un premier accord et la résolution
de l'accord vous allez mettre une fausse
note ce que vous allez considérer comme
une fausse note
mais ce n'en est pas une parce que dans
l'ensemble de la partition
la fausse note a permis de mettre en
valeur et de générer une notes
harmonieuses par la suite alors je sais
la fumée qui sort des oreilles parce que
c'est quelque chose à quoi j'ai pensé et
voulu développer et ça ça m'a permis de
faire ça s'il ya un moteur dans ma vie
c'est ça je peux tout oublié je peux
tout enlever ce que tout arrêter du jour
au lendemain mais saches veut pas et ça
c'est la deuxième anecdote ça sera la
dernière parce que j'arrive à ham et 18
minutes je sais pas si j'ai changé le
monde
mais la musique est et c'est pour ça que
j'ai pris la métaphore de la musique
pour parler de la résilience à ma
manière
ce que j'aurais jamais la prétention
d'en parler comme boris cyrulnik qu'il a
bien étudié ce concert qu'on a fait
c'était il ya quatre ans on a repris les
pink floyd à notre manière on n'a pas
voulu faire du copier coller et tout le
monde m'a dit mais tu es fou mais
personne ne va venir mais les marocains
aiment pas et puis vous aurez pas arrivé
à le faire et on n'a pas eu de sponsors
on a tout fait sur nos deniers propres
j'ai même perdu beaucoup d'argent sur ce
coup là que j'ai mis trois ans à
rembourser mais la résilience qu'on a
développés pour faire ça avec près de
3500 personnes qui sont venues voir le
concert et avec un an une synergie
absolument incroyable qu'on a fait dans
la résilience parce que tous les jours
il fallait battre des obstacles tous les
jours eh ben ça si moi j'ai une fierté
et une émotion à retenir c'est bien ça
et enfin
et là j'en arrive finalement à définir
avec lui parce que s'il ya quelqu'un qui
m'a marqué c'est bien miles davis et il
m'a marqué parce que la première fois ce
que je vous ai mis dans en sous titre et
qu'il fallait jouer la contre contre la
mélodie de la con tre mélodie on se dit
c'est pas possible
miles davis était le roi de ça et tu es
le roi des bonnes fausse note
c'est à dire que vous croyez toujours
qu'il était en train de jouer une fausse
note
alors que finalement il retombe toujours
sur ses pattes
et pour ça je me dis avec sa voix à
chaque fois je l'aimais est ce que je
suis en train de nager contre le courant
acheteur
il aura terme
j'ai toujours une mélodie dans la
mélodie une cascade et vous continuez à
l'infini et on avance merci à vous
[Musique]